Transcription: Viji Gowri
Relecteur: Guillaume Rouy
(Musique générique)
(Applaudissements)
Bonjour la Sorbonne !
Ça vous est déjà arrivé
de partir en randonnée
et de réaliser après
une, deux, trois heures de marche
que vous avez oublié
les sandwichs dans le frigo ?
Qu’est-ce qu’on fait
dans ces cas-là, quand on réalise
qu’il va falloir tenir une journée entière
sur un seul paquet de biscuits ?
Si je suis avec mes frères,
clairement on se bat.
Mais entre gens civilisés,
qu’est-ce qu’on fait ?
On prend le paquet de biscuits,
on distribue entre les randonneurs,
en espérant que ça tombe juste
et chacun mange ses biscuits
quand il le souhaite.
À la fin de la journée,
on a mangé un paquet,
strictement, pas une miette de plus
et chacun était libre de ses choix.
Cette philosophie, c’est la philosophie
de fond du quota carbone individuel
dont j’aimerais vous parler aujourd’hui.
Mais avant cela,
remettons les choses en perspective.
Après plus de 40 ans de
négociations internationales sur le climat
la quasi-totalité des pays du monde
s’est engagée à atteindre
la neutralité carbone,
d’ici la seconde moitié du siècle.
C’est ça, l’accord de Paris.
Mais ça ne va pas assez vite…
Le dérèglement climatique
quand je suis né,
c’était des prévisions scientifiques
dans d’abscons rapports de 5000 pages,
mais aujourd’hui, c’est l’actualité :
inondations torrentielles en Europe,
incendies inarrêtables
en Amérique du Nord,
migrations causées par l’aridité
en Afrique, tout ça était prévu
et tout ça se réalise.
« La Terre, » disait Paul Éluard,
à juste titre,
« est devenue bleue comme une orange. »
Dans l’urgence, la France a mis en place
une taxe carbone il y a 7 ans.
Diluée dans le prix de l’énergie,
elle devait augmenter progressivement
de façon à orienter nos comportements
mais on a vite vu
les limites de ce système.
Payer une dizaine de centimes d’euros
supplémentaires par litre d’essence
n’a pas le même effet quand on est au RSA
ou quand on gagne un SMIC par jour.
Parce que oui, ça existe.
Dans le premier cas, ça peut vous empêcher
de satisfaire vos besoins fondamentaux,
comme de vous chauffer, par exemple,
et dans l’autre cas ça ne change rien
à votre consommation.
Autrement dit, la taxe carbone était
soit trop faible pour être efficace,
soit trop inégalitaire
pour être acceptable et donc pérenne.
Comment atteindre la neutralité carbone
dans un esprit de justice sociale ?
Alors...
on pourrait commencer
par transformer la taxe carbone,
la rendre plus égalitaire
en redistribuant une partie
de ses revenus aux plus défavorisés ;
mais, après les gilets jaunes,
ça risque de prendre beaucoup de temps
avant de reconstruire la confiance.
On pourrait tout miser
sur la technologie :
oui, si demain matin
on trouvait une solution
pour se débarrasser des déchets nucléaires
ou recycler les terres rares
des énergies renouvelables,
le problème climatique serait quasi résolu
-- quasi.
Mais ce serait un pari,
et aujourd’hui on ne peut plus
se permettre de faire un pari.
Alors, on pourrait interdire.
Ouais, interdire, tout simplement -
la consommation de viande,
les résidences secondaires,
les voyages en avion, peu importe.
Toutes ces consommations évitables
pourraient être interdites
au regard du chaos climatique
mais je pense que ni vous
ni moi n’avons envie
de confier de telles
prérogatives à l’État.
Alors nous voilà, au point de départ.
Comment allier
la liberté de la taxe carbone,
c’est à dire, la liberté de choisir
sa propre consommation
à l’efficacité de l’interdiction ?
Le tout dans un esprit de justice sociale.
Ça ressemble à une impasse.
Mais souvenez-vous de mon histoire
de paquet de biscuits en randonnée ?
Si on faisait exactement la même chose
avec des gaz à effet de serre.
Je m’explique :
chaque année, une agence d’État,
définirait un volume d’émissions maximum
à ne pas dépasser
pour respecter l’accord de Paris.
Ce volume, dont on retirerait
les émissions collectives,
serait divisé en parts strictement égales
par résident français.
Chacun aurait donc
une sorte de compte carbone,
qui serait renfloué automatiquement
chaque année
et débité à chaque consommation
de produits carbonés.
Alors quels produits vous me direz ?
Un litre d’essence évidemment,
un téléphone,
une place de théâtre, une andouillette
au restaurant, peu importe.
En fait, aujourd’hui, tout produit
émet directement ou indirectement
des gaz à effet de serre.
Donc, tout produit
devrait être concerné par ce dispositif.
Et ensuite, l’entreprise, le restaurant,
la troupe de théâtre répercuteraient
ses émissions de production
sur le consommateur
tout comme aujourd’hui ils répercutent
ses coûts de production.
Le premier avantage d’un tel dispositif,
ce serait de respecter les budgets
carbones nationaux ; ce n’est pas rien.
La France n’a jamais réussi à le faire.
C’est principalement dû à une chose :
les instruments économiques
et les normes écologiques en général,
sont des instruments relatifs.
Je prends un exemple tout de suite.
Vous prenez les normes des voitures
en grammes de CO2 par kilomètre.
Ça parait efficace.
Mais si à la fin de l’année,
vous roulez toujours plus,
vous émettrez toujours plus.
Émettre moins de CO2 par kilomètre,
par kilo de bœuf produit,
par mètre carré de logement,
même par point de PIB, ça favorisera
mais ça ne garantira jamais
la réduction d’émissions.
Le quota carbone,
fondé sur une logique de contrainte
non plus relative, mais absolue
permettrait de contourner cette impasse.
Deuxième point qui permettrait
d’être résolu :
réduire les inégalités
dans le processus de décarbonation.
Là où aujourd’hui la taxe carbone frappe
le premier centilitre d’essence
consommé par la boulangère
qui va au travail à 5h du mat
et qui est payée au SMIC,
le quota exonérerait
les besoins fondamentaux par construction
et ne toucherait
que les consommations évitables,
obligeant les catégories de population
les plus aisées,
à faire des choix.
Mais au lieu de confier à l’État
le soin de restreindre
certaines consommations :
prendre l’avion, manger de la viande ;
chacun serait libre de choisir
ce à quoi il souhaite renoncer.
Pourquoi par exemple,
interdire à une voyageuse passionnée
de prendre l’avion
une fois de temps en temps,
si par ailleurs elle est
strictement végétarienne,
n’achète rien de neuf
que ce soit des vêtements ou des produits
électroniques et n’a pas de voiture.
À ce stade vous devez avoir
beaucoup de questions.
La première c’est souvent :
qu’est qu’on ferait
en cas de quotas excédentaires :
si à la fin de l’année on a
des quotas excédentaires ?
Ça dépendra de votre
philosophie politique.
Soit vous adhérez à la notion
de droits à polluer ;
dans ce cas une personne
détentrice de quotas
pourra les revendre
sur un marché carbone.
Soit au contraire, vous considérez
que les gaz à effet de serre
sont une pollution irréversible,
ils ne peuvent donc pas être
monnayés, financiarisés ;
dans ce cas l’agence d’État
récupérera les quotas
contre indemnisation, puis les détruira.
On peut aussi envisager une solution
intermédiaire, où il serait possible
d’acheter et de revendre les quotas
dans une certaine limite.
Deuxième question -
peut-être plus importante encore :
comment faire pour ces personnes
qui, faute de revenus,
ne peuvent pas isoler leur logement
qui est une passoire thermique,
ne peuvent pas changer
leur véhicule polluant.
Donc ces personnes excèdent leur quota
carbone avant même la fin de l’année.
Pour répondre à ça,
il faudra réorienter une partie
des aides publiques à la transition.
Là où aujourd’hui, elles financent
de façon souvent généralisée,
le changement de véhicule ou
la pose de panneaux solaires,
elles devront se focaliser
sur la décarbonation
des besoins fondamentaux
des personnes les plus défavorisées.
Mais les personnes les plus favorisées
ne sont pas moins incitées
à isoler leur logement
ou à changer leur véhicule
parce qu’elles souhaiteront conserver
leur quota pour d’éventuels loisirs.
Troisième et dernier point :
comment faire avec
ces émissions importées ?
Vous savez que tous les téléphones
qu’on a dans nos poches,
Apple ou Samsung, ne sont pas produits
en France - ça se saurait.
Donc toutes les émissions
liées à votre consommation
qui ont lieu à l’extérieur de la France.
Chaque français émet en moyenne
une tonne de CO2 en Chine, chaque année.
C’est un chiffre
du Haut Conseil pour le Climat.
Alors comment les prendre
en compte dans notre système ?
En vérité, en ce moment même
la Commission Européenne réfléchit
à une taxe carbone aux frontières.
Ça veut dire que nous avons l’information
carbone sur les produits qu’on importe.
Donc il sera possible
d’intégrer les émissions importées
dans le dispositif.
Cent autres questions seraient légitimes :
à quel âge on aurait notre quota carbone ?
Comment faire avec ces biens qui sont
très émissifs à la construction,
mais ensuite permettent
un comportement plus vertueux ?
Comment faire pour adapter
le quota individuel
aux modes de vie
ruraux, urbains ou insulaires ?
Je sens la curiosité qui pétille
dans vos regards…
mais je pourrai pas y répondre,
je n’aurai pas le temps, il y en a trop.
Ce que je veux vous
transmettre avant tout
c’est ma conviction
que le quota individuel
permettrait d’allier 3 choses que nous
sommes incapables d’allier aujourd’hui.
La radicalité collective,
c’est-à-dire, la certitude
d’atteindre l’accord de Paris,
la neutralité carbone ;
La liberté individuelle maximale :
l’État ne viendrait pas vous expliquer
que vous devez pas prendre l’avion
ou consommer de la viande, vous ferez
vos choix en conscience dans cette limite
et la justice sociale.
Alors oui, le dispositif paraît
un peu complexe,
mais franchement, pour un pays comme
la France, qui a inventé la TVA,
ça ne va pas nous inquiéter !
Ce n’est pas une blague !
La France a inventé la TVA, maintenant
ça représente la majorité des budgets
de plus de 150 pays dans le monde.
En France on essaie de briller autrement,
avec les macarons La Durée,
la Tour Eiffel, les sous-marins,
le transfert de Messi au PSG,
mais tout ça,
on pourrait briller autrement.
Imaginez, seulement dans trente ans,
la France a atteint,
le monde a atteint la neutralité carbone
sur la base de deux choses :
l’accord de Paris - de Paris -
et le quota carbone individuel,
imaginez, mis en place
pour la première fois en France.
Classe, non ?
Un dernier point.
Ça fait des décennies
qu’on parle de sobriété.
Elle figure même dans la loi,
comme ça, pour faire joli…
sobriété énergétique, sobriété numérique…
mais c’est vrai, c’est joli.
Mais la vraie sobriété,
la culture de sobriété,
nécessitera une bifurcation
bien plus profonde.
Alors les mondes culturels et associatifs
commencent à décoloniser nos imaginaires,
pour reprendre l’expression
de Serge Latouche,
mais ça risque de ne pas aller assez vite.
En matérialisant très concrètement
au quotidien
une limite environnementale
dans l’intégralité de nos échanges,
le quota carbone individuel permettrait
de retisser ces liens rompus
entre notre économie,
et le vrai monde.
Si je vous ai convaincu, creusez l’idée.
Elle est complexe, très riche,
elle présente mille avantages
et mille inconvénients
peu importe les points que j’ai mis
devant vous aujourd’hui,
elle mérite d’être débattue.
Si je ne vous ai pas convaincu,
ce que j’envisage,
gardez comme idée sous le coude
pour le repas de famille,
ça vous changera de discussions
sur le passe sanitaire,
croyez-moi, ce ne sera pas moins animé.
Je vous remercie.
(Applaudissements)
(Musique générique)